. We now have the absolute final numbers for
not only Donald Trump but Melania Trump. We are
turning the page. We are starting a new era. It
is the Joe Biden era. And what is an unfortunate,
irreversible reality now that Trump has done is
that Donald Trump has exited as the least popular
president in history for as long as there has been
polling. And Melania Trump, not to be outdone,
is the least popular first lady in the history of
the U.S. for as long as there has been polling.
I gave you the numbers yesterday. According to
Pew Research, Trump's approval bottomed out at
twenty nine percent yesterday on Gallup.
Trump bottomed out at thirty four percent.
But we now have the presidency wide numbers
trumps average approval throughout his presidency
is 41 percent. That is the least popular president
in the history of the polling era. Trump also
the only president never to at any time in the
Gallup tracking survey, have 50 percent approval.
So Trump never hit 50 percent.
Averaged forty one, a low of any
president in history and going out at 34,
the lowest of his entire presidency. Now,
strictly speaking, it's an appeal to authority
to say that a president's popularity tells us if
they were a good or a bad president. That's
not what I'm doing. I'm not saying Trump
was good or bad on the basis of his approval.
I am merely telling you that the guy obsessed with
good marks and popularity and feeding his ego and
being well liked is the least well-liked president
in the history of the United States during
the polling era. Similarly, Melania Trump
leaving the White House with the worst popularity
rating for any first lady at the end of her term
in polling history. CNN SRS has Trump at 42
to 47. First ladies are just popular, you
might say. Well, 42 is not that bad. First ladies
often have 60 or even 70 percent popularity. Um,
it's it's really something else. And to be to be
perfectly frank, Melania was barely a first lady.
She didn't do and didn't appear at many of the
things and in many of the places that first ladies
traditionally have appeared at, she was a complete
and total nonfactor. It seems pretty clear she
wanted nothing to do with this presidency. And it
seems pretty clear, at least from time to time,
it wasn't clear she wanted much to do with Donald
Trump. So we're really closing the book on this
in a way that it's really not sad for me.
The sad part is that their approval is even
as high as it is. As I've said before, their
approval ratings should be dramatically lower.
But as far as Donald Trump famously said,
it is what it is. And Trump will go into
history as the least popular president
in the history of the United States.